Hi guys, this is Joel with the Taproot Therapy Collective Podcast and today we're going to do a guided meditation that is for anger and letting go of anger and resentment. So before we start, I want to make sure that you're in a safe place that is good and is comfortable. And make sure you're not driving or doing something that requires concentration before you begin a meditation like this It doesn't really matter the posture as long as it's comfortable and it lets you pay attention to The sensations that are around you So I want you to take a deep breath in and out In and out And make sure that you're breathing all the way to the very bottom
大家好，我是Taproot Therapy Collective播客的Joel。今天我们要进行一次引导式冥想，主题是关于愤怒，以及如何放下愤怒和怨恨。在开始之前，请确保你处于一个安全、舒适的环境中。在开始这样的冥想之前，请确保你没有在开车或做任何需要专注的事情。姿势并不重要，只要舒适，能让你专注于周围的感觉即可。现在，请深吸一口气，然后呼出。吸气，呼气。确保你的呼吸深入到肺部最底部。
of your lungs so you're breathing air in and then you're breathing it out but when you do that you're feeling your chest fill all the way up until it's almost slightly uncomfortable and then breathing all the way out in a deep belly breath. And I want you to imagine that you're standing at the foot of a lush green forest and there are tall evergreen trees that sway gently before you in a warm breeze and still living needles glisten in dappled sunlight filtering the light and the clouds as they move and interlace and interweave across your vision and the dead needles from the pines are on the ground at your feet. And you notice a well-worn path that leads into these woods.
这样你吸入空气，然后再呼出。当你这样做时，你会感觉到胸腔完全充满，直到几乎感到轻微的不适，然后深长地呼气，进行腹式呼吸。想象你正站在一片郁郁葱葱的森林边缘，高大的常青树在温暖的微风中轻轻摇曳。活着的针叶在斑驳的阳光下闪烁，过滤着光线和云朵，它们在你的视野中移动、交织、缠绕。松树掉落的枯针铺在你的脚下。你注意到一条通往森林深处的小径。
And you hear the birds and you feel the wind on your face, drying the sweat because you're so tired and you have a backpack that is very heavy that you have to carry and no one will carry it for you and you can't put it down. And all of this has fallen to you to do. And the straps of the backpack are padded but it's so heavy that the padding is pulling into your shoulders and you feel how much sweat is underneath the backpack between your shirt and your skin where the skin can't breathe and this pack contains a lot of responsibility for anger and resentment. It's an obligation and it's fallen to you and it's heavy and you have to step forward and you feel the pine needles crunch under the rubber of your boot but
你听见鸟鸣，感受到微风拂过脸庞，吹干了汗水，因为你太累了。你背着一个非常沉重的背包，必须背着它，没有人会帮你背，你也无法放下。所有这一切重担都落在了你的肩上。背包的带子虽然有衬垫，但因为太重，衬垫深深地勒进你的肩膀。你感觉到背包下、衬衫和皮肤之间积聚的汗水，皮肤无法呼吸。这个背包里装满了愤怒和怨恨的责任。这是一种义务，它落在了你身上，它很沉重。你必须向前迈步，感觉到松针在你的靴底发出嘎吱声，但
you feel extra weight with every step because you're carrying such a heavy pack. And it doesn't bother you because you're the one that has to carry it. And you breathe in that fresh piney air, Breathe in that fresh, piney air. The sap from the living green needles mixing with the crunch of the dead needles under your feet. And they're kind of tannic scent, both of those things in the air. And there's a slight breeze. And you hear nut hatches and different bird calls. And you see birds moving through
每走一步，你都感到额外的重量，因为你背着如此沉重的包。但这并不困扰你，因为你是那个必须背负它的人。你吸入那清新的松木气息，吸入那清新的、松木的气息。活着的绿色针叶散发的树脂味与脚下枯针的嘎吱声混合在一起。空气中弥漫着一种单宁般的香气。微风拂过，你听见鳾鸟和其他各种鸟鸣。你看见鸟儿在
the forest, other things crunching the pine needles too. And you continue on this well worn trail into the forest. And you keep walking and feeling the weight of this thing. And the canvas rubs against your shoulders and you feel the pain radiating out. That's kind of a tight heat in the center of your chest, maybe under your ribcage a little bit. There's kind of a clammy sweat in the center of your chest under your t-shirt and you feel that same pain kind of going through your torso up underneath your shoulder blade from the way that you have to lean forward and brace against the weight of the pack and you feel that pain under your shoulder blade radiating down your back in a tight tension that is hot and also running all the
森林中穿梭，还有其他东西也在踩踏着松针。你继续沿着这条被踩踏出来的小径走进森林。你继续走着，感受着这东西的重量。帆布摩擦着你的肩膀，你感到疼痛向外辐射。那是一种紧绷的热感，位于胸腔中心，也许在肋骨下方一点。你的T恤下，胸口中心有一种湿冷的感觉。你感觉到同样的疼痛穿过躯干，向上延伸到肩胛骨下方，这是因为你不得不向前倾斜，以支撑背包的重量。你感觉到肩胛骨下的疼痛向背部辐射，形成一种灼热的紧绷感，并一直向上
way up from your shoulder blade up the two tendons on the side of your neck on either side of your skull and you have to pull your head forward with your nose up because your spine is bending down to brace against the weight as you walk. And you feel this heat rise up your neck and pull under your hairline where the air can't make contact with your skin. And as you go along this trail, your pace slows and you feel the gravel and the clay where there are no pine needles under the path and your foot can skitter through the sandy gravel and the rocks
延伸，从肩胛骨一直到颈部两侧、颅骨两侧的两条肌腱。你不得不把头向前拉，鼻子向上，因为你的脊椎为了支撑重量而弯曲。你感觉到这股热量顺着脖子升起，拉扯着发际线下方，那里空气无法接触到你的皮肤。随着你沿着这条小径前行，你的步伐变慢了。你感觉到小径上没有松针的地方是碎石和粘土，你的脚可以在沙砾和岩石中滑动。
And it's slightly wet and you have to make sure that your footing is make sure that your footing is sure with every footstep because you have to carry this pack and your thigh muscles quiver with this effort of this weight that is yours and no one else's and you feel your kneecaps lock when there's twinges of pain that shoot through your ankles and your knees. Your whole body feels rigid and strained and each joint hurts and it's hurt for a long time. It's hurt for a long time. And that anger sort of radiates through you, pulsing with the pounding of your heart. It's not just in the backpack. It's in your body.
地面有些潮湿，你必须确保每一步都走得稳，因为你必须背着这个包。你的大腿肌肉因为背负这属于你、且无人能分担的重量而颤抖。你感觉到膝盖骨锁死，一阵阵疼痛穿过脚踝和膝盖。你的整个身体感到僵硬和紧张，每个关节都在痛，而且已经痛了很久了。已经痛了很久了。那种愤怒在你的体内辐射，随着心跳脉动。它不仅仅在背包里，它在你的身体里。
And part of you resents this burden even though you know you have to do it and that it's yours to do. And there's a longing to take it off and to run away into the woods, but another part of you whispers that you have no choice and it's your obligation to carry these festering emotions and responsibilities and no one else can do it for you and it's your job to be the beast of burden and your mind wrestles with this conflict as you trudge onward down the path and it's darker under the trees, it's cooler, the sun isn't on your face and the wind can whistle underneath the tall branches of the pines above you. You can see the
你的一部分怨恨这种负担，尽管你知道你必须这样做，这是你必须完成的任务。你渴望把它脱下来，跑进森林里，但另一部分你在低语，说你别无选择，背负这些溃烂的情绪和责任是你的义务，没有人能替你做。你的工作就是做这头负重的牲畜。当你拖着沉重的步伐沿着小径前行时，你的内心在与这种冲突搏斗。树下更暗，更凉爽，阳光照不到你的脸上，风可以在你上方高大的松树枝下呼啸。你可以看到
tall trunks going on forever in a field of dark green and brown and the majority of the branches are tall, far above your head making a ceiling. It doesn't let through very much sunlight and you can hear squirrels. And you can hear birds on the bark of the trees and the branches. And then you walk onward. And it's so dark under the trees that you don't realize that after you crest a hill, You're coming up on a glittering pool of water that is clear and undisturbed. There's small ripples from the wind and you see this shimmering pool of clear water and it's in a small glade and there's mossy boulders encircling the pond like
高大的树干在深绿色和棕色的原野中延伸，无穷无尽。大部分树枝很高，远在你头顶上方，形成了一个天花板。它透进来的阳光不多。你可以听见松鼠的声音。你可以听见树皮和树枝上的鸟鸣。然后你继续向前走。树下太暗了，以至于你没有意识到，当你翻过一个小山丘时，你来到了一潭波光粼粼的水池前，水面清澈而平静。风吹起细小的涟漪，你看见这潭闪烁的清澈水面，它位于一个小林间空地上。长满苔藓的巨石环绕着池塘，就像
they're guarding it and there's a shaft of golden light that pours down through the canopy around the opening of the pool in the forest and there's reflections dancing on the mirror-like surface of the water reflecting the golden shaft of light up against the underside of the canopy of pine needles in places and the sight makes your heart feel heavy but calm and the cool wind coming off the water starts to give you a chill in your skin as the temperature changes. You walk to the edge of the pool and you pull the pack off one strap at a time and unbuckle the strap that runs around your belly and take the strap off of your left shoulder and off of your right shoulder And it feels odd to stand straight It feels odd to breathe deeper now
它们在守护着它。一道金色的光束穿过森林中水池开口处的树冠倾泻而下。水面上倒映着金色的光束，在镜面般的水面上舞动，在某些地方反射到松针树冠的下方。这景象让你的心感到沉重但平静。从水面上吹来的凉风让你的皮肤感到一阵寒意，因为温度发生了变化。你走到池边，把背包一根带子一根带子地脱下来，解开绕在腹部的带子，把带子从左肩和右肩上取下。站直的感觉很奇怪。现在呼吸更深的感觉很奇怪。
And you feel the cool air across your face and your nose And you feel it rush into your lungs with every breath and you feel your heart pumping as your blood pressure is up and you feel your heart become cooler and you feel the sensation coming back into your shoulders and the tendons that run up the back of your neck as they can relax and feel their sensation all of a sudden they don't have to strain and you can feel the wet sweat that the straps were pushing into the shirt and all of a sudden as that water starts to cool off and dry out in the wind so much heat is wicked away from your body in these places that were painful. And all the way down the straps, down the shoulder to across the lumbar where the weight of the pack was resting against your back.
你感觉到凉爽的空气拂过你的脸和鼻子。你感觉到它随着每一次呼吸涌入你的肺部。你感觉到心脏在跳动，因为血压升高了。你感觉到心脏变得凉爽，你感觉到肩膀和颈部后方的肌腱恢复了知觉，因为它们可以放松了，突然间它们不再需要紧绷。你可以感觉到带子压在衬衫里的湿汗，突然间，随着水开始变凉，在风中变干，这些疼痛的地方带走了身体大量的热量。顺着带子，顺着肩膀，一直到背包重量压在你背上的腰部。
And you feel these kind of stagnant aches start to relax and you realize that you've forgotten what it feels like to inhabit your body without the clamp of straps and buckles and the pack sits on a rock waiting for you. It's not gone but you're free of it. You can have the pack and you can also be free from time to time. And you take what feels like your first full breath filling your lungs with air and cool temperature and life and you kick off dip one toe into the water and its coolness laps at your skin inviting you in and you peel off your socks and you feel the water in a ring circling your foot as it goes deeper and deeper of your ankle now And then up to your knee and you hop off the rock with a splash and you feel the silt Going up in between your toes washing away sweat and grime.
你感觉到这些停滞的酸痛开始放松，你意识到你已经忘记了在没有带子和扣环束缚的情况下生活在自己身体里是什么感觉。背包放在一块石头上等着你。它没有消失，但你从它身上解脱了。你可以拥有这个背包，但你也可以不时地获得自由。你深吸了一口气，感觉像是第一次完全填满肺部，吸入空气、凉爽的温度和生命。你踢掉鞋子，把一个脚趾伸进水里，它的凉爽拍打着你的皮肤，邀请你进去。你脱掉袜子，感觉到水环绕着你的脚，随着它越来越深，现在到了脚踝，然后到了膝盖。你跳下石头，溅起水花，感觉到淤泥
Cool silt at the bottom of this pool. And the water is blue and gem-like. And the water envelops your calves now. Making them shake and then be still in your thighs and your hips and it seems to dissolve these miles of tension from walking and you sigh deeply and relax into the silky embrace of the water and you feel that ring of water move up your waist around your belly button and then up your midsection and you allow yourself to float and surrender to the gentle support of the water and you feel weightless and unbound as it wets your
在脚趾间升起，洗去了汗水和污垢。池底凉爽的淤泥。水是蓝色的，像宝石一样。水现在包裹着你的小腿，让它们颤抖，然后平静下来，接着是你的大腿和臀部。它似乎溶解了行走带来的数英里紧张感。你深深地叹了口气，放松地沉浸在丝绸般的水的怀抱中。你感觉到那圈水向上移动，绕过你的肚脐，然后向上到你的腹部。你让自己漂浮起来，臣服于水的温柔支撑。你感到失重和无拘无束，水打湿了你的
hair and you feel your hair floating as the water is all the way around your ears in the middle of your skull and the top of your hairline is still your forehead hot and sweaty but the base of your skull is so cool as you float and it cradles you like a child in the arms of the earth and that anger and obligation melt off of your body as you are transmuted swirling away into the sacred pond and there's some old wise part of you that knows And there's some old wise part of you that knows that you can be responsible and you can still relish freedom and you can have bad things happen to you but that you can still be good, that life can still be good and that you can lose things and that you can gain things and that things can change and things can grow like little shoots coming up through the grass that look
头发，你感觉到头发在漂浮，水完全环绕着你的耳朵，在你的颅骨中间。发际线顶部依然是你的前额，又热又汗，但颅骨底部却如此凉爽。当你漂浮时，它像孩子一样在地球的怀抱中摇篮着你。那愤怒和义务从你的身体上融化，当你被转化，旋转着进入神圣的池塘。你内心深处有一个古老而智慧的部分知道，你内心深处有一个古老而智慧的部分知道，你可以负责任，你仍然可以享受自由。你可以经历糟糕的事情，但你仍然可以是好的，生活仍然可以是好的。你可以失去一些东西，也可以获得一些东西。事情可以改变，事情可以像穿过草地的小芽一样生长，看起来
like brushes or koosh balls that are bright green of tiny pine trees that one day grow into the big pine trees that make the canopy all around the pool and the golden shaft of light shines down on your face on the top of your forehead are the only things that have not gone under the water yet. And you take a deep breath and you go all the way under the water. And you are more than what you are thinking about. And you are the parts of yourself that are seen by others and that are unseen by others. And immersed in the stillness know that you can be responsible and joyful.
像刷子或Koosh球，是微小松树的亮绿色，有一天会长成高大的松树，形成池塘周围的树冠。金色的光束照在你的脸上，前额顶部是唯一还没有没入水下的部分。你深吸一口气，完全没入水中。你不仅仅是你所思考的那些东西。你是你自己被他人看到的部分，也是他人未曾看到的部分。沉浸在宁静中，要知道你可以既负责任又快乐。
You can be happy and mature. You can be purposeful and also playful. And these qualities can go exist and overlap. They don't contradict. And they complement and enrich one another. And your multiplicity enriches you. And you feel your capacity for lighthearted, uncomplicated joy expanding and cradled by the water you realize that you can be independent and vulnerable, self-reliant and also softly open. And the more you embrace your own tender humanity, the more resourced you are to stand tall in your singular strength. And there is a power in yielding and a stability in letting go and dissolving and there is strength in surrender and as you absorb these insights you begin to understand that at your core you are the space that holds
你可以快乐而成熟。你可以有目标感，也可以充满玩心。这些品质可以共存并重叠。它们并不矛盾。它们相互补充和丰富。你的多样性丰富了你。你感觉到你对轻松、简单快乐的容量在扩大。被水环绕着，你意识到你可以既独立又脆弱，既自立又温柔地开放。你越拥抱自己温柔的人性，你就越有资源在独特的坚强中挺立。屈服中有一种力量，放下和溶解中有一种稳定性，臣服中有一种力量。当你吸收这些见解时，你开始明白，在你的核心，你是那个容纳
all opposites without tension and the awareness in which all experiences arise and dissolve anger, peace, connection, solitude are all you. You are partially known and partially unknown. And they all come and go like ripples on the surface of the pond water above you but underneath the movement you are the water itself vast and clear and unchanging and here you can welcome all the colors of your life with a wide open heart. You can allow anger to flow through you without damning your aliveness. You can be responsible adult and spontaneous child, a solitary voyager, and stand in the web of belonging.
所有对立面而没有紧张的空间，是所有体验产生和溶解的意识。愤怒、平静、连接、孤独，都是你。你部分被知晓，部分不被知晓。它们都像你上方池塘水面的涟漪一样来来去去，但在运动之下，你就是水本身，广阔、清澈、不变。在这里，你可以用一颗宽广开放的心欢迎你生命中所有的色彩。你可以允许愤怒流过你，而不损害你的生命力。你可以是负责任的成年人，也可以是自发的孩子，是一个孤独的航行者，同时站在归属感的网络中。
And there's room for all of it in the generous space of your true nature. And carry this spaciousness with you. You always carry this spaciousness with you. You always carry this spaciousness with you and remember what you were not always aware of but you always know. And all of a sudden in the depths of the water you feel a depth to yourself. There is more to you than you can see at any moment. There is parts of you that are known and parts of you that are unknown. Even if you're feeling something strongly in one moment it is not all of you because there is so much more now that you know and you know that there are parts that you
在你的真实本性的宽广空间里，这一切都有容身之处。带着这种宽广感。你总是带着这种宽广感。你总是带着这种宽广感，记住你并不总是意识到，但你总是知道的事情。突然间，在水的深处，你感觉到自己的一种深度。你比你在任何时刻所能看到的要多得多。你身上有被知晓的部分，也有未被知晓的部分。即使你在某一刻强烈地感受着什么，那也不是全部的你，因为现在你知道的更多了，而且你知道有些部分你
cannot know like the depths of the water like the deep black and the bottom of the water you cannot all be seen and you cannot all be seen even by yourself in any one moment cannot be yourself in any one moment. Cannot be known even by yourself in any one moment. What you are, the depth of what you are, and the things that you connect to, and the things that cradle and hold you even when you do not notice them. And for a few moments you soak in this peace and remember this feeling of being cleansed and renewed and reborn and the water is so cold all around you and you feel it wash away the sweat and the dust and the flecks of the red clay on your bare legs. You carry it back with you this awareness as you return along the forest path, moving with lightness
无法知晓，就像水的深度，就像水底深处的黑暗。你无法被完全看见，即使在任何时刻你自己也无法被完全看见。在任何时刻都无法成为你自己。在任何时刻，即使是你自己也无法完全了解。你是什么，你深度的本质，以及你所连接的事物，以及即使在你没有注意到时也摇篮和支撑你的事物。片刻之间，你沉浸在这种平静中，记住这种被净化、更新和重生的感觉。水在你周围如此寒冷，你感觉到它洗去了汗水、灰尘和你裸露腿上的红粘土斑点。当你沿着森林小径返回时，你带着这种意识，带着轻盈
and ease in your refreshed body. You will take it back with you a bit of this place this hidden depth because you know now that you can be responsible and you can also be free you can have obligation and you can also have freedom. You can be important and you can also have freedom. You can feel trapped but there are parts of you that can always be free and you breathe in and you allow these realizations to settle not just into your muscles or your tired skin but all the way down into your bones so you will always know them and for a few moments more soak in the peace and remember this feeling of being cleansed and renewed and reborn and carry it back with you as you return along the forest path moving with a new lightness now and a new ease and a
和轻松，在焕然一新的身体中移动。你会带回一点这个地方，这种隐藏的深度，因为你现在知道你可以负责任，你也可以自由。你可以有义务，你也可以有自由。你可以很重要，你也可以有自由。你可以感到被困住，但你身上总有一些部分是可以自由的。你吸气，允许这些领悟沉淀，不仅仅是沉淀到你的肌肉或疲惫的皮肤里，而是沉淀到你的骨头里，这样你就会永远记住它们。再沉浸在平静中片刻，记住这种被净化、更新和重生的感觉，并带着它返回，当你沿着森林小径返回时，现在带着一种新的轻盈
refreshed ability to carry this pack because the journey is not over but you now understand that you can pick up your duties without losing yourself. The people can do things to you that do not have to control or change all of who you are. And you've learned a precious secret now that anger can be released back into the earth, that it is only a moment but not ever real, it grows too heavy and you can re-emerge restored into your true essence and you can be part of the world and you can have feelings and you can have events happen to you but you can still be whole outside of these moments
和一种新的轻松，以及一种焕然一新的能力来背负这个背包。因为旅程还没有结束，但你现在明白，你可以拿起你的职责而不失去自我。人们可以对你做一些事情，但这些事情不必控制或改变你的全部。你现在学到了一个珍贵的秘密：愤怒可以被释放回大地，它只是一个瞬间，但永远不是真实的。它变得太重了，你可以恢复并重新浮现，回到你真实的本质。你可以成为世界的一部分，你可以有感受，你可以经历事件，但你仍然可以在这些时刻之外保持完整，
that take things away, that make a part of you feel you can still be resilient and you can be free. And I want you to gradually let your awareness return to the present moment, to the surface beneath you and the gentle movement of your breath and know that you can return to the forest pool in your imagination whenever you feel unburdened and experience this release again and again and it is always there beneath you in the deep waters of a well that live inside of you and under you and your connection to the web of all of the things that make you up and make you part of the world and the unbounded wisdom of your heart is always there, waiting to welcome you home.
那些带走东西的时刻，那些让你的一部分感到你可以仍然有韧性并且可以自由的时刻。我希望你逐渐让你的意识回到当下，回到你下方的表面和你呼吸的轻柔运动。要知道，每当你感到负担减轻时，你都可以在想象中回到森林池塘，一次又一次地体验这种释放。它总是存在于你下方，存在于你内心深处和下方的深井中，存在于你与构成你并使你成为世界一部分的所有事物的网络中。你内心无边无际的智慧总是在那里，等待着欢迎你回家。
And when you're ready, I want you to begin to wiggle your fingers and toes, and your renewed connection to your body and take a deep breath in and out. And when you're ready, gently open your eyes if they're closed. Return to normal breathing if you're still carrying the meditative breathing with you and then try and carry this sense of spaciousness and possibility into your next project and to your next moment in time. if if if if if if if So So So I'm going to go back to sleep. We will never sleep There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
当你准备好时，我希望你开始动动手指和脚趾，感受你与身体重新建立的连接，深吸一口气，然后呼出。当你准备好时，如果眼睛闭着，请轻轻睁开。如果你还在进行冥想呼吸，请恢复正常呼吸。然后尝试将这种宽广感和可能性带入你的下一个项目和下一个时刻。如果如果如果如果如果如果如果所以所以所以我打算回去睡觉了。我们永远不会睡觉。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。